le métier que vous nauriez pas aimé
faire bourreau avant
81 le questionnaire alors Robert banater
votre mot préféré justice le mot que
vous détestez racisme le votre drogue
favorite le travail le son le bruit que
vous
aimez la vague bruit de la mer et le son
le bruit que vous détestez à le cllaxant
et le votre juron gros mot blasème
favori merde ah c'est pas mieux c'est
pas plus original plus original non
classique vous n'avez jamais changé je
crois pas non non classique fidèle vous
êtes finalement très classé hom ou femme
pour illustrer un nouveau billet de
banque écoutez sérieusement
condorsa pour me faire plaisir Elisabeth
balinter et puis ça ennuira Pau
vert pas du tout non non mais je en ai
jamais voulu au contraire d'abord elle a
fait publicité feuassade c'était pas
l'objet c'est bien fait bon le métier
que vous n'auriez pas aimé faire
bourreau avant 801 oui oui et
aujourd'hui fini c'est fin à la retraite
d'ailleurs j'ai veillce qu'il une
pension la plante l'arbre l'animal dans
lequel vous aimeriez être
réincarné le renard le renard parce
qu'il veut toujours être libre vous
rappelez plutôt perdre la queue c'est la
coupée que d'être retenu dans le piège
le renard le renard dans une émission
érotique ça
c'est en si Dieu existeiez-vous après
votre mort l'entendre vous dire à vous
Robert
B tu as fait ce que tu as pu
entre
[Musique]